congrats on maverick it's going
fantastic what do you think of the fan
response to this thing i mean it's kind
of mind-blowing it's been awesome man
i've never really experienced something
like this in my life tom before i signed
on to this he did he tried to lay out
what it would what it would be like and
the anticipation for this film and and
how how much fans you know really one
want this movie and how hard it was
going to be to satisfy them but just
based on the you know the reaction and
you know the box office and everything
we you know we did it so it's just it's
a really good feeling
[Music]
i don't know if you're even aware of
this but like your social network you're
a sensation dude like the the teller
teller talk
people are freaking out about that
you're dancing
they say you're starting a revolution
with this are you even aware of it or
you're just out there having a good time
not real i mean i a little bit just
because i don't have you know uh
instagram or tick tock or anything but i
know my i know my wife i'll just see her
on her phone and then she'll start
cracking up and so then she shares with
me um you know what's going on but i
mean yeah it's great if it if it brings
people into the you know in the theater
or
i don't know
gets some new fans maybe for me yeah
that's that's all good listen man you're
just so likable it is what it is like
don't don't don't change anything i just
had to bring it up because it's really
as a married man me and my wife are
always doing goofy things but i just see
the beautiful relationship there and
it's you know
that's you don't have to try to do
anything man that's that's what it's all
about man i i try and you know my
i love making movies but my you know my
personal life and my time with kelly and
you know my family and my friends those
the moments i really you know i really
see
what you want is redemption
and this is how are you gonna find it
we're selling peace in the harmony
itself
[Applause]
[Music]
what a ride an unexpected twisted
awesome thrill ride i mean caught me
caught me off guard man but bravo
thank you thank you appreciate it i
think that was the
you know when you sign on to a movie
like this where when you read it it's
you know it's science fiction and it's
in its drama and it's action and it's
just a really bizarre world that we got
to live in for a while so thank you for
saying that all the congrats in the
world and now you and joe have kind of
collaborated on a few projects what's
the deal man what do you what do you
enjoy so much about working with joe
he's very talented he's he's a guy that
i think
visually i think he's one of the best
visual
um storytelling you know directors that
we have he's really he's really
confident and he's really competent in
his ability to create these worlds
and as an actor
it takes a lot of the pressure off when
you know
when you know the quality behind the
camera i think that takes a lot of the
pressure off because you know
that your efforts are going to be
validated at the end you know it really
is a director's medium so if you can
find a couple directors that you feel
really confident in
i i think you should try and work with
them all the time
i love that and i have to say i'm gonna
i'm gonna quote it exactly this is vice
versa because joe thinks the world of
you i mean he said you're one of the
most talented actors of this generation
so he imagines that you're able to bring
these real emotions required because of
real experiences
what i mean what do you say to that dude
i mean that's high praise coming from
him well i wrote that for him to say so
that's why
that's a boy
no i mean look joe at this point he's
you know we've went well beyond kind of
a professional or just a
a limited professional only relationship
joe is somebody that that we talk all
the time and he's he's somebody that i
just really really admire and i think we
yeah i think i think it's working so
we'll keep doing it until people stop
watching let's talk about working with
chris real quick uh what was the
experience like did you guys did you
discuss your marvel connection at all
anything like that how was the
experience i think i think
chris's marvel connection has been a
little more fruitful
than
mine and i say that because i saw his
house in his house out there in
australia is pretty big but no i mean
chris look he's somebody that i was
really excited to work with i had met
him once or twice and
you know everybody who meets chris works
with chris they we pretty much all have
the same things to say about him just
he's a he's an incredible
person and he's he's a wonderful scene
partner and yeah he's he's just a great
guy man he's he's really wonderful
overall the experience of this thing i'm
gonna let you get out of here what was
what was a high point for you making
this movie i know i talked to chris and
it kind of all happened pretty quickly
um but man there's some just some really
strong emotional beats in this what was
the what was the high point for you i
mean going to set every every day
was
i knew was going to be a challenge
because the the script really does ask a
lot of the of the performances in it
just with the the constant you know
you're under manipulation from somebody
else so that's always tough things
are happening very quickly and kind of
you know turning on a dime but i you
know for for being a pretty small cast i
just i really loved journey and
and chris and and i also i felt really
grateful because we filmed it in the
middle of covert and it was a time when
so many of my buddies who were actors
you know were out of work and directors
and everything so
i think
i was just really appreciative to be
working
[Music]
you